[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily a
guilty verdict after weeks of testimony
and hours of deliberation in the federal
fraud trial of elizabeth holmes plus a
lot of cases end with the murder
this one it's just a small piece of the
puzzle
chandler halderson killed his parents on
july 1st 2021. prosecutors in defense
argue their case in opening statements
for the wisconsin murder trial of
chandler hulderson and a british royals
lawyers argue a 12-year-old settlement
bars a woman from suing him we'll
discuss the latest in the civil sex case
against prince andrew then later jury
selection is delayed again in the
retrial for accused murderer deonte
rosales law on crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin after weeks of testimony and over
50 hours of jury deliberations we
finally have a verdict out of the
california courtroom former ceo
elizabeth holmes is found guilty on some
of the fraud charges she faced after
days of deliberations the jury returned
a verdict on eight of the 11 charges on
monday jurors indicated they couldn't
come to a unanimous decision on three
counts the judge issued an allen charge
and instructed them to return to
deliberations the federal jury convicted
the founder of the failed blood testing
company theranos of four counts of
defrauding investors and found her not
guilty of charges relating to patients
it was previously believed that theranos
would revolutionize blood testing but
there were issues with the company's
technology prosecutors argued holmes
lied to investors to gain clout for
theranos and raise hundreds of millions
of dollars in funding her defense team
blamed other leaders within the company
including ceo and former boyfriend of
holmes ramich sunny bhawani he is
charged with similar crimes and is set
to go to trial next month homes now
faces up to 20 years behind bars a fine
of a quarter million dollars and
restitution for each count
let's bring in l.a county deputy public
defender philip dube and terry austin
phillip were you surprised by this mixed
bag of guilty not guilty and hung
charges especially not guilty for
defrauding patience
not at all in fact i was actually quite
heartened by it keep in mind this jury
was out for several weeks and it sounds
like they gave their undivided attention
to each and every count and they
evaluated all the evidence and heard
testimony to see if each element of each
charge was proved beyond a reasonable
doubt and for those counts that they
felt that the people or the prosecution
did not prove up they they found her not
guilty and uh where you had a split in
that poll
uh they deadlocked and the ones where
there was reasonable doubt they found
her not guilty let's just wait and see
if they decide to retry her on the hung
counts yeah and i bet you that uh her
ex-boyfriend sonny is also looking at
these charges as well to try to
anticipate what he's going to do now
terry with a verdict like this what's
next for holmes
well she's out on bail she walked out of
that court and the next thing we're
going to see is a pre-sentencing report
and soon obviously we'll get that
sentencing date so she's facing 20 years
in bridges for each account and so
basically i think they're going to be
served concurrently there's no minimum
sentence here and then of course the
judge is going to look at the federal
sentencing guidelines and she has no
prior record so i think she's going to
probably just get a sufficient amount of
time but something that's necessary to
show restitution here yeah i definitely
agree concurrent is definitely the uh
more unlikely but consec is something
that her defense team is definitely
going to be worried about to see if
these charges will stack on top of each
other or served at the same time as
terry said we'll find out as the days
continue
new developments as andrew cuomo dodges
not one but two legal battles this comes
just days before his next court date the
former governor will not face criminal
charges on allegations that he sexually
assaulted and aid the complaint filed in
october came two months after he
resigned amid his sexual harassment
scandal it alleged cuomo had put his
hands under a woman's shirt in 2020
around the same time he was publicly
accused of groping an assistant brittany
camiso at the executive mansion
albany county's district attorney said
in a statement tuesday morning that a
thorough and independent review of the
investigation was over and the
allegations couldn't be proven in court
unrelated to the sexual misconduct
allegations cuomo also won't be charged
in connection to his former office's
handling of the kovan 19 pandemic cuomo
allegedly under counted nursing home
deaths from kova 19 by as much as 50
percent but after an investigation there
was no evidence that any laws were
actually broken
last month cuomo was also formally
ordered to relinquish earnings from his
book about the covet pandemic after was
determined he used state resources while
writing it
now to missouri where a man convicted of
murder will spend the rest of his life
in prison in october a jury found
michael humphrey guilty of first-degree
murder in armed criminal action for his
part in the shooting death of famed
snake breeder benjamin renick
prosecutors say humphrey drove his
ex-girlfriend the victim's wife lindley
renick to kill her husband at the
couple's farm in june of 2017.
after his conviction humphrey made a
deal in exchange for his testimony
against renick in her trial last month
and also led police to the murder weapon
rennick was convicted of second-degree
murder in early december in her
husband's death both trials told the
story of reneg conspiring with humphrey
and an employee of the spa she owned
ashley shaw to kill her husband
prosecutors say humphrey also gave
rennick the gun used in the shooting it
took me nearly two and a half years and
a tip from another boyfriend of renek
for the police to target her as the
prime suspect humphrey is sentenced to
life in prison with the possibility of
parole with a reduced charge of
second-degree murder and his armed
criminal action charge was dismissed
still ahead on law and crime daily
prince andrews lawyers won a sexual
assault lawsuit against him tossed what
the judge said about one of the duke of
york's arguments coming up
but first opening statements and the
first witnesses take the stand as the
chandler holderson's murder and
dismemberment trial gets underway in
wisconsin
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily we head
to wisconsin now where opening
statements are presented in the trial of
chandler holderson the 23 year old is
accused of killing and dismembering his
parents bart and krista halderson and
lying to police about them going missing
this all happened around the fourth of
july holiday last year halderson's
father's remains were found days after
he reported him missing his mother's
remains were found a few weeks later
police say halderson made google
searches like body found and wisconsin
dismembered body found before his arrest
halderson faces multiple charges
including first degree intentional
homicide false information on a
kidnapped or missing person mutilating a
corpse and hiding a corpse on tuesday
the prosecution presented its opening
statement detailing the gruesome way
bart hardelson's body was discovered
someone had crudely chopped off the head
the arms
and sawed off the legs
in the middle of the thigh
leaving the underwear on
in the beginnings of the pants
they removed the sticks and brush over a
course of a few hours they brought out
doctors from the medical examiner's
office to make sure everything was done
appropriately
they rolled the torso over
there were gunshots in the back
this man had been shot in the back
and chopped up
the defense followed with its brief
opening statement urging jurors not to
convict halderson
i'm going to ask you to
resist some things in this case as
jurors
we already talked a little bit about
proof beyond a reasonable doubt
what that means is you must resist
guessing
you must resist speculation
you must resist storytelling
and only convict
when you're when it's proven or if it's
proven which it won't be beyond a
reasonable doubt
i'm going to ask you to resist losing
your objectivity
objectivity may be hard for people in
this case because of the graphic nature
what you've just been told or what
you're going to see
but you need to resist losing that
objectivity
commit to being jurors just passionate
logical
don't be swayed by fear
and i ask you to resist any pressure you
might feel to convict
mr halderson of murder in this case
law and crime sierra gillespie is in
madison for the start of harlison's
trial we caught up with her as
opening arguments began
brian day two of wisconsin versus
chandler halderson began in madison
wisconsin in the shadow of the capital
here at the dane county courthouse it
kicked off with prosecution opening
statements delivered by dane county
assistant district attorney william
brown now he detailed for more than an
hour to jurors what led up to and what
followed the deaths of bart and christa
halderson he detailed to jurors what he
said defendant chandler halderson made
in discrepancies when he was
interviewing with police he also showed
jurors where bart and christa
halderson's remains were later found
even saying that halderson chopped up
their bodies with knives and with a saw
before burning their bodies in the
family fireplace now on the opposite end
of things we also heard from defense
attorney katherine dorrell she delivered
a comparably shorter opening statement
only lasting about 10 minutes in which
she reminded jurors that they need to
presume chandler halderson innocent and
reminded them to keep in mind reasonable
doubt now she ended that opening
statement basically by saying chandler
holderson did not kill his parents now
the rest of the morning and into the
afternoon on tuesday included several
state witnesses who were involved in the
chandler-halterson investigation law and
crime will continue to follow this case
from gavel to gavel so stay with us for
the latest developments for long crime
daily i'm sierra gillespie
thank you sierra let's jump into this
new trial
with la county deputy public defender
philip dube and terry austin phillip
what were the strongest parts of the
defense's opening and did it raise any
reasonable doubt
well the strong part was that she is a
strong advocate for her client obviously
right she didn't just phone it in now on
the other hand it really was sort of
that tony robbins robin slow
walk if you will to a pep talk and
typically whenever you really don't have
a an affirmative defense or exculpatory
facts you basically argue lady liberty
the constitution and reasonable doubt
and it seems like that's what she's
hanging her hat on here all right i
would agree but don't give away all of
our uh tricks out of the bag as public
defenders phillip uh terry what's the
goal of the prosecution's opening and
did they achieve it
well the goal brian is to make sure that
they lay out what the story is and you
have to be clear you have to be concise
and you also have to be passionate you
have to describe the events in detail
without giving too much minutia because
you don't want to lose that jury and
here the prosecution william brown did
an excellent job he accomplished all of
that he told the jury what led up to
that murder he told the jury exactly
what that murder was how it happened
after the murder that he dismembered
those bodies and he made it clear what
the motive was that the son wanted to
basically cover up how his life was
failing
right interesting how that plays out it
almost seems like two different types of
personalities at least in the opening
statements thus far if you want to watch
more of wisconsin versus chandler
holders and make sure to watch the law
on crime network for gavel to gavel
coverage coming up on law and crime
daily prince andrew's case goes to court
asking that a sexual abuse lawsuit be
thrown out what his lawyers had to say
and why he believes his friendship with
jeffrey epstein could help him in the
case
plus a florida court case is delayed
once more why deontay rosalis has to
wait two more weeks to be trot retried
for a 2014 murder
[Music]
welcome back lawyers for prince andrew
argue in federal report that he can't be
sued by a woman accusing him of sexual
abuse because of a 12-year-old agreement
she made with convicted sex offender
jeffrey epstein law and crime's angela
levy is here with what happened in court
brian virginia jufree is suing prince
andrew saying she was forced to have sex
with him when she was younger than 18
but the duke of york is pointing to a
2009
agreement a settlement that juve free
agreed to with epstein
and he says that that bars her from
suing him now jufree accepted a 500 000
payout from epstein and agreed the
settlement would remain confidential the
settlement though also protects quote
other potential defendants prince
andrews lawyers say that would include
prince andrew but juffrey's lawyers say
this applied to people involved in
trafficking jufree and she was
trafficked to prince andrew which he
denies jewfrey's attorney david boyce
says the settlement does not shield
prince andrew from litigation because it
applies to things that happened within
the jurisdiction in florida and the
agreement was with epstein so only he or
jufree could enforce it now judge louis
kaplan said he will issue a decision on
prince andrew's motion to dismiss soon
but he said the scheduling order for the
case will remain in place it will not be
stayed meaning that both sides will
continue to exchange evidence with one
another in discovery brian
thanks internet back to breakdown the
latest in the prince andrew hearing is
l.a county deputy public defender philip
dube and co-host terry austin terry
what were your thoughts on the argument
that a third party like prince andrew
can't use this agreement as a defense
i thought the argument was unique you
know agreements like this are not
uncommon third parties can benefit from
a settlement agreement the judge seemed
to think that only the parties in the
agreement can enforce it but i think
that argument surprised both council
counsel for andrew was trying to say
that he was in the category of protected
people and of course david boyce dufre's
lawyer was arguing that it couldn't be
held as far as prince andrew was
concerned because he did not fall into
the category of people doing the
trafficking as anjanet said so we'll
just have to wait and see he said he'll
make his decision soon and i think
prince andrew will be sweating over that
decision well i'm not sure according to
him he can't sweat we'll we'll wait for
that discovery though philip as i
listened to it was interesting the judge
seemed to guide drew frey's
lawyers to arguments he agreed with and
really push back on prince andrew's
lawyers how should we read into that
well it sounds like the judge had
reached a tentative ruling and was
relying on the arguments of counsel to
be goaded into a position either way but
it sounds like he was tending to rule in
favor of um
of
the woman who entered into the agreement
with epstein now to be fair i think that
prince andrew does have a claim uh as a
third-party beneficiary to that
settlement agreement between epstein and
joffrey or however you pronounce her
name i apologize
um
the state of florida recognizes
third-party beneficiaries that are not
named in contracts if the parties
actually intended such uh
unknown unnamed third parties to benefit
and in paragraph two of the agreement
they actually mention
that uh the class of people to benefit
from the contract include those who
could have been named as defendants
and clearly uh prince andrew belongs to
that class and even though he may not
have known anything about this agreement
he has the right to benefit from it
under florida law yeah phil i'll even
add one more point that as well it also
lists a category of people that being
royals and jeanette the judge took issue
with one of prince andrew's arguments in
the court what was it
yeah brian prince andrew's attorney
andrew brettler he said that virginia
dufrey and her complaint in her lawsuit
really didn't lock in a story she didn't
give you know a date where she says
prince andrew assaulted her she only
made general allegations that she was
abused in gelane maxwell's home in
london but judge kaplan told brettler
quote
that dog is not going to hunt here he
said that that will not be a basis for
dismissing
the lawsuit dismissing the complaint and
he said that that argument was not going
to hold any water with him we'll check
on the hunting dogs as that judge gives
us a decision soon as they said and
we'll continue with that case thank you
all for your updates when we come back
more delays in the trial of accused
killer why the judge has pushed back
jury selection as deante rosales is
retried for a 2014 murder
welcome back in florida on tuesday jury
selection was delayed again in the
murder trial and the retrial for deontay
rosales over problems with evidence
part of the issue is the state's hair
sample lab report is not ready yet the
defense wants to have their own
specialists take a look at the evidence
themselves the judge felt the case is
not ready for trial so he continued it
until january 18th rosales is charged in
the 2014 murder of jill halliburton sue
sue was found tied up and stabbed to
death in her bathtub prosecutors say
rosales burglarized sue's home and
killed her when he discovered that she
was there rosales's case went to trial
in november but after five days of
deliberation it resulted in a mistrial
when one juror disagreed with a guilty
manslaughter verdict rosalis also made
headlines in 2016 when he escaped the
courthouse during a hearing
he was on the run for six days before
authorities caught up with him if
convicted rosales faces the death
penalty
phillip why do you think there are so
many evidence delays in a retrial
shouldn't all the evidence be out there
already
well the short answer is it depends
sometimes uh when a
the original trial deadlocks
council has an opportunity maybe out in
the halls to debrief the jury as to what
they felt was missing or what they could
have done differently who knows maybe a
couple of the jurors voiced some
concerns about the forensics and the
biological evidence and it kind of
tipped off defense counsel to do more
work and investigation in the lab
additionally it could be about funding
maybe the money wasn't there at the time
that they needed the expert and now they
were able to convince a judge to give
them the funding uh plus it takes time
you know it could be that at the time
they really needed this information the
labs were backlogged and they couldn't
get a technician in place to actually
test the specimen so it could be a host
of factors but the bottom line is deonte
is entitled to due process and that
means he has the right to the
help if you will of all the ancillary
services of experts private labs and
government labs to find the truth
all right i agree and we'll see how it
pans out from the coming weeks terry
when the trial does start what themes or
questions do you think the prosecution
will ask in selecting jurors well one of
the things i think the prosecution is
going to ask is about the death penalty
because this is a potential death
penalty case to make sure that the views
of the jurors are such that they could
impose or rather vote guilty as far as
the defense is concerned so i think
they're going to make sure that they get
a jury who can listen to all the
evidence all right we'll see how it
plays out thank you both and thank you
for joining us here at long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you